[Music]
I'm Benedict from pop exporter I'm here
at Burke high n Cantina in Berlin where
ace T is about to perform her video for
bist du down really made a big splash in
2017 it was even a big internet hit in
America she kind of came out of nowhere
and was really cool down-to-earth and
relaxed I wonder if she's really like
that or is she kind of a diva let's find
out thanks very much for being able to
meet with us to perform so let's get
started one song everyone's dying to
hear is bist du down does that ever get
annoying I'm looking to the future to my
album and I envision doing a lot more so
know what was it like to be celebrated
by the whole world as a new voice of R&B
it felt nice that people around the
world appreciated what I was doing
[Music]
the video was a huge YouTube hit even in
the u.s. why do you think it caught on
internationally I have no idea I mean
the track is in German and I think it's
nice that it's having success
internationally nice German sounds super
aggressive to people in other countries
and not really cool but somehow people
think it's vibey
you could have looked for a label in the
US and brought out track after track but
you've waited to see what would happen
how come I still have to develop a bit
I've been making music for a while now
and I had to figure out what was right
for me and what wasn't I want to try
things out and work with different
people
you mentioned the future so what's next
for you musically speaking
I will then planning my album sip slow
and it's definitely going to come out
this year what will it be like R&B it's
pure R&B funk slow vibes and a bit of
up-tempo too
a Steve Christie some iced tea is really
likable and totally relaxed we have to
set up lighting and sound and she put up
with it all
she even hugged the whole team at the
end she's promised a new album this year
so we'll keep you posted
[Music]